hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
what aspect of stoic ethics that many
people approaching it for the first time
or just beginners and it find
particularly difficult to grasp is what
the Stoics called the entire realm of
indifference and the fact that
indifference could in fact have some
value
they could be preferred or they could be
rejected there's different ways of
translating this without having goodness
or badness within them sometimes people
think the Stoics are just juggling with
words and that's in fact one of the
criticisms that gets made of cato and
the Stoics in cicero's on the ends not
only in book three but in in other
places but the Stoics wanted to resist
calling a whole host of things genuinely
good or bad and they wanted to reserve
the terms good and bad just for what
they regarded as being genuinely or
fully good and bad so they use this term
in different IDF fora
for the entire realm of things that
could have some value but they don't
have the value of goodness or badness
they could be useful or harmful there's
a whole bunch of other things they could
be reasonable or unreasonable but
they're not genuinely good or bad so
I've got this schema that replicates
what the Stoics talked about and how
they in fact treated these things let's
take a look at what we've got on both
ends on the one end genuine goodness the
Stoics included more the morally right
the hone estimate Latin and the virtues
and moral rightness and the virtues are
essentially the same thing the virtues
being for the Stoics primarily justice
courage temperance and wisdom there were
a lot of other sub virtues underneath
them as well
they also included in this discussion a
friend as somebody who's productive of
goodness and wisdom is something that is
both goodness for its own sake but also
productive of goodness
then on the other end we way at the
other extreme are the opposites of these
right the morally wrong the turqu been
the word that we get turpitude from an
old-fashioned way for saying somebody is
terrible or disgusting right and the
vices the vices are the opposites of the
virtues the vices are injustice or
unrighteousness if you like which would
also include you know since justice
includes benevolence it would include
malevolence doing harm to other people
for its own sake rather than helping
them cowardice which also would include
rashness in temperance or lack of
moderation when it comes to the
appetites and desires and of course
folly or foolishness the opposite of
wisdom now at both of these extremes are
to be found happiness eudaimonia and
misery
the Stoics held that the only things
that really make us happier miserable
are the things that are genuinely bad or
good so you want to be happy you have to
be virtuous you have to cultivate the
virtues you want to be well nobody wants
to be unhappy but if you want to avoid
being unhappy it better give some
thought to not developing those vices
right and everything else in between is
strictly speaking indifferent it doesn't
how is it indifferent it doesn't make a
difference to whether you are happy or
virtuous or whether you are miserable
and vicious no amount of these preferred
or rejected indifference can change your
condition if you are virtuous it doesn't
matter in some respect
whether you're wealthy healthy it
doesn't matter if you're wise of course
because
that's one of the virtues but good looks
you can be completely virtuous and
terribly ugly that is in fact one of the
rejected indifference and it's not going
to change you being virtuous or there by
being happy according to the Stoics this
is a very counterintuitive notion when
you think about it in terms of how we
comport ourselves in the world today and
it was a counterintuitive notion even in
the stoic zone time they found
themselves having to invent new
vocabulary just to make this point let's
talk now about this whole realm of the
indifference they're not without value
some have positive value it's just not
the kind of value that you can add up to
produce moral goodness
some of them do in fact have negative
value not just not the kind of negative
value that is automatically going to
make you vicious and unhappy as a result
if you are made unhappy by these it's
likely because you're also vicious so
what are they he gives a number of
examples Cato in book three and many of
these can be paired off against each
other wealth versus poverty right it's
good for buying things when you have
money or you have property or you have
income credit even right and poverty you
think about lack of good credit in our
own time and the hindrances that that
creates for people and or the additional
you know entrances into further poverty
that it creates for people but those are
strictly speaking in different bodily
health it's a good thing except the
Stoics wouldn't say it's good it's a
preferred indifferent right
same thing with illness a rejected
indifferent honor or a disgrace same
thing good looks versus ugliness having
your senses in good condition the Latin
there is actually the word that we get
integral from being whole being healthy
so being able to see well you know maybe
in heating glasses is actually a
rejected indifferent although having my
glasses is a preferred indifferent if I
lose my glasses I'm kind of screwed I
mean I can see the camera but it's kind
of a blur you know all of those sorts of
things are good examples pleasure or
freedom from pain that's the preferred
and different pain bodily pain mental
trouble those are rejected indifference
and when we use these terms preferred
and rejected we are saying that they do
have some sort of value they just don't
have the kind of value that generates
moral goodness or moral badness or evil
if you like so let's look a little bit
closer now at this term that's being
used so and I've got an H in there just
to help with you know sort of the
derivation and pronunciation preferred
is a term that the the Stoics are coming
up with in Greek Zeno is writing in
Greek as our really everybody up until
Cicero and prohibit hey Hague menon
means sort of led before you know lead
in in front of or if you like advanced
or set in a state of eminence you could
say so he gives the example of a king
and a king's court you don't call the
king preferred because the king is at
the top level the king is the one who
makes the decisions the king has the
greatest dignity the king has the
greatest rank or eminence so the king
would be corresponding to the good here
right and then the thing that's
preferred is something that is advanced
like a counselor
the counselors not necessarily of royal
blood but he or she is brought forward
by the king almost to the point where
they can act in the king's place in
order for you know the court to operate
properly all right because the King
isn't going to be everywhere there are
other concerns and functions going on so
that's one way to understand it
other metaphor that he gives he's
talking about throwing knucklebones
right and knucklebones are essentially
dice so you're you're trying to throw it
so it stands up right in a particular
way it happens to fall that way you know
getting it to stand up right in the
right way would be the equivalent of the
good but just happening to fall in that
way would be the equivalent of the
preferred indifferent another way that
perhaps helps us to understand this a
little bit better but it does appeal to
a concept that's quite complex within
the stoic ethics is that preferred
indifference are in some way in
accordance with nature and rejected
indifference Apple Eggman those that are
being sort of led away those are against
nature in some way or not in accordance
with nature in some way and you can
think about this pain there's a great
example now in a certain sense you can
say that any pain that you experience is
in accordance with nature because it's
part of the way the universe works you
know poke yourself in the eye you're
gonna feel pain but you shouldn't be
poking yourself in the eye right and and
pain is usually a signal that something
is going wrong in some way with the
bodily organism that you have where as
freedom from pain could be something you
know that is in accordance with nature
and we can go on and on and on now
there's a third distinction that gets
made or a third explanation and this is
particularly important and it's even
going to lead us to a little bit of a
disagreement among the Stoics so we have
things that are preferred for their own
sake what would be examples of those as
Cato gives the example of good looks or
a good expression on the face a certain
expression a certain way of looking we
could probably also say that pleasure
fits in there as well why do we prefer a
pleasure because it's pleasant we enjoy
it right then there's some that are
preferred Annika
countess something else which it
produces and wealth is the prime example
of this why do you want money if you
want money just for the sake of having
money there's something wrong with that
reasoning process because money is for
buying things money is for producing
things money is for getting things done
and it doesn't really have any value by
itself other than that yeah I mean you
can say well you can exchange it with
somebody else for something else or you
can use it to invest well that's all
ultimately going to be about somebody
getting something out of it and it's
going to be some preferred and different
that they're getting out of it right
we're avoiding some rejected and
different you might say that some of
these other things like healthy senses
could be understood as just productive
but actually they would probably fit
into this third category where it's for
both reasons and Cato gives the example
of health saying that health is
preferred not just for its own sake but
also because it is productive of other
things if you're healthy then you're
also probably going to be able to enjoy
pleasure you're probably going to look
better you're going to have freedom from
pain you know we could go on and on and
on and we could think about the senses
we enjoy using the senses but they're
also productive they help us to do other
things as well and there's a very
interesting discussion here about you
know fame or glory he says Chris Tempest
and Diogenes used to say that aside from
any practical value it may possess you
know like the fact that you're famous
gets you into a restaurant for example
it is not worth stretching a finger out
for and I strongly agree with them which
would mean that it would be in the class
of the productive right the second class
here and then he says on the other hand
their successors declared that good fame
was preferred and desirable for its own
sake and that a person of good breeding
and liberal education would desire to
have the good opinion of his parents and
relatives and have good people in
general and that for its own sake and
not for any practical advantage
they were locating it in the first class
so you have a disagreement here within
the stoic school about precisely where
to class some of these indifference but
they are saying that fame or honor is in
the class of the preferred the only
question is why is it in there
and you can similarly say something
although Cato doesn't go into this about
the rejected and difference some of them
we reject for their own sake we don't
want to feel pain for example right some
of them we reject because they are
productive of other things poverty is
productive of a whole bunch of other
deprivation
illness we you know perhaps we reject
for its own sake and also because it's
also productive of other things like say
poverty or ugliness or bad senses or
pain and I think you could similarly say
that the Stoics might have a
disagreement about disgrace why is
disgrace negatively valued it could be
because it's negatively valued for its
own sake or it could be because it leads
to other sorts of problems you know
think about if you become a pariah in
social media the fact that you might get
fired and lose your your job and no
longer have any money or it may cause
you pain in other respects so we have
this entire realm of the indifference
which do in fact matter to some degree
the one thing we haven't talked about is
is there anything that's genuinely
indifferent and Cato doesn't talk about
this here but the Stoics did believe
that there were some things that were
totally indifferent one of the examples
that you'll find elsewhere in Diogenes
lair taste and in areas didymus as
epitome of stoic ethics is the number of
hairs upon a person's head really quite
a matter of indifference now you might
say well somebody's going bald maybe
they would actually care very much about
that sort of thing but that would be
because they're interested in that
because of good looks not because of the
sheer number of hairs on one's head and
we could think of some other things that
are genuinely and different so you can
see that the Stoics they say that
there's
good and there's bad and then everything
else is in the middle but the stuff in
the middle really does matter and can be
positively or negatively valued
you